Hallo Guten Tag, nehmen Sie den Platz. Mein Name ist Tejan, ich bin der zuständiger Autosatastion für die
gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch führen. Zunächst werde ich Ihnen ein paar Argumente
fragen, danach können Sie mir eine aktuelle Beschwerde schildern. Wenn etwas unklar ist,
fragen Sie bitte nach. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Karl Weiß.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren vollen Unklangnamen langsam auf Buch stabilieren?
Mein Vornamen ist K, wie Konrad, H, wie Anton, R, wie Richard, L, wie Ludwig.
Man nachher ist weiß, wie die Farbe weiß.
Okay, mit K oder mit C?
Karl?
K, wie K, mit K.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Karl Weiß.
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 8. April 1960.
1960.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,65 m groß und wiege circa 75 kg.
85?
75.
Wie viele Beschwerde haben Sie, Herr Weiß?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit 3 Tagen bestehende Schmerzen im Unterbauch habe und auch Fieber habe.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich den Unterbauch schon mehr. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Mitte bis linke Unterbauch.
Mitte und linkseitig.
Genau.
Schmerzen, die Schmerzen sind sehr wichtig.
Bis in die Leiste.
Sie haben eine Schmelz, die Sie haben.
Nein.
Sie haben eine Leichtung, die Sie haben.
Nein, ich habe nicht mehr.
Sie haben eine Schmerz, die Sie haben.
Schmerzen?
Ja, Schmerzen.
Sie können das bitte.
Das sind eher so drückende, stechende Schmerzen, die ich habe.
Drückende und stechende.
Stechende.
Herr Weiß, wie haben Ihre Schmerzen angefangen?
Langsam oder plötschlich?
Es war so ein plötzlicher Stechen.
Jetzt werden die Beschwerden der Abstand immer mehr.
Ich habe immer wieder diese Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ab und zu haben Sie Schmerzen und manchmal haben Sie keine Schmerzen.
Nacht habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Nacht habe ich zum Beispiel sehr, sehr selten Schmerzen.
Nachts keine Schmerzen.
Selten, ja.
Okay, selten.
Michael, habe ich schon diese Beschwerden.
Gib das bestimmte Auslöser, haben Sie etwas bemerkt
oder was verlindingen, verlindingen Ihre Schmerzen
und was verstecken?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich drauf drücke, tut das sehr weh.
Wenn Sie draußen sind?
Wenn ich drauf drücke.
Dann habe ich Schmerzen, wenn ich drauf drücke.
Was meinen Sie?
Wenn ich auf meinen Bauch drücke, dann tut das weh.
Ah, okay, okay. Ja, während drücken ist das Schilema.
Richtig.
Ist das abhängig vom Essen, vor dem Essen, nach dem Essen, gibt es Veränderung?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Ja, Herr Weiß, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Stark.
Ja, ich meine, auf einer Schmerzkalauffon 1 bis 10.
1 bedeutet sehr leicht und 10 bedeutet sehr stark.
Ja, so ungefähr 6 bis 7.
6 bis 7.
Unser Gespräch wird ungefähr 20 Minuten lang.
Das kann ich auch noch machen.
Das ist besser, danke.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen zum ersten Mal aufgetreten oder früher hat sie eigentlich beschwerden?
Ich habe diese Schmerzen noch nie gehabt, sollt es schmerzen.
Zum ersten Mal.
Seit 3 Tagen, ja, waren Sie bei Ihrem Hausarzt,
oder haben Sie als Medikamentös etwas angenommen gegen Ihre Schmerzen beschwerden?
Ich war noch nicht bei meinem Hausarzt.
Ich habe Paracetamol angenommen.
Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Ein wenig.
Wie sind Sie die Dosierung?
Eine Tablette habe ich genommen.
Ein Tablett?
500 Milligramm, ich glaube, richtig?
Kann sein.
Mein Tablett, und es hat ein bisschen geholfen.
Genau.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Ich habe etwas Fieber, ja, habe ich gesagt.
Ich habe circa 38,5 Fieber.
38,5.
Wann haben Sie gemessen?
Ich habe gestern Abend gemessen.
Gestern Abend.
Haben Sie William Gern oder Vollegefür in Ihrem Bein?
Nicht wirklich, aber ich habe ein bisschen Übelkeit.
Übelkeit?
Haben Sie Alburochem?
Nein.
Haben Sie noch weitere begleitende Beschwerden?
Ich habe etwas Stuhl- und Regelmäßigkeit.
Ich habe manchmal Verstopfung und manchmal habe ich leichten Durchfall.
Seit wann?
Seit zwei Tagen.
Das ist auch seit zwei Tagen.
Und momentan oder seit drei Tagen hatten Sie auch Durchfall.
Ich habe nicht durchfall.
Ich habe ja wechselnde Stuhlgang.
Ob Verstopfung oder Durchfall.
Hatten Sie Farbeveränderung bemerkt?
Oder haben Sie Blut bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Aber ich habe bemerkt, dass der Stuhl manchmal fester ist, manchmal weicher ist.
Manchmal fester, manchmal weicher.
Gibt es Mengenveränderung bei Ihrem Stuhl?
Hab ich nicht draufgeachtet.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen herweiss?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Husten Sie oder haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig herweiss?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Waselassen?
Gibt es Farbeveränderung oder welche andere Bechwerden?
Ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie in Leicester-Side ab oder zu genommen?
Ergleich geblieben.
Wie ist der Appetit herweiss?
Eigentlich gut.
Gibt es kein Problem?
Wie ist der Schlaf? Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja.
Herr Weiss, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich leite an Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck?
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ich habe das schon seit 10 Jahren.
Ich glaube, 11 Jahre habe ich das.
10 Jahre oder 11 Jahre?
Gibt es noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, so weit ich weiß nicht.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck ein?
Ich nehme Ramie-Pril ein, 5 Milligramm.
Und morgens nehme ich auch HCT ein.
12,5 Milligramm.
HCT?
Ah, okay.
12,5 Milligramm morgens.
Und Ramie-Pril auch morgens?
Beides morgens, ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Weiss?
Ich wurde eigentlich an meinem Knie einmal operiert,
das vor 20 Jahren, am linken Knie.
Linken Knie.
Ja, was passiert?
Ich habe einen Knorpelproblem gehabt.
Die haben gesagt, dass es eine Atrose war.
Atrose, okay.
Vor 20 Jahren?
Ja, ich habe ein neues Gelenk bekommen.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie allergenote Unfertigkeiten, Herr Weiss?
Nicht das Schluß.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Weiss?
Ich rauche ja.
Seit wann?
180 Jahre.
Wie viel Zigarette täglich, wissen Sie?
Ungefähr 10 Stück.
10 Stück?
Nehmen Sie Alkohol süßig, Herr Weiss?
Ganz selten.
Was trinken Sie und wie häufig?
Wein.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nicht wirklich.
Dafür bin ich zu alt.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ich gehe viel spazieren.
Wie oft?
Jedem Tag oder zwei, drei Mal pro Woche?
Fast jeden Tag spazieren.
Sehr gut.
Herr Weiss,
leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, beide verstorben.
Tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Woran sind Sie verstorben
und welche kröntischen Erkrankungen Sie haben?
Weitere haben noch Bluthochdruck
und mein Vater ist an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Tut mir leid.
Ich habe eine Erkrankung.
Ich habe sie gestorben.
Tut mir leid,
woran ist Ihre Mutter gestorben?
Die war Alte.
Sie war Alte, gingen sie gestorben?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Man stirbt etwas älter.
Er determinantiert sich auf einen Leuchten pre Justice.
Sie ist ein Leuchtt deployLIght.
Man ist sch876 pragmatic.
IchaciMusic,
ich weiß,
Was hat sie? Ein Blutzucker? Blutzucker-Irion?
Äh, Typ 2.
Wie bitte?
Ich habe eh nicht so gut gehört.
Blutzucker-Erkrankung?
Ja, Typ 2 oder Typ Meister, wissen Sie?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Äh, ja, seit wann hat ja ihre Schwester diese Krankheit?
Ich glaube, sie war 45, hat das angefangen, 45 Jahren.
Im Alter von 45 begonnen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Herr Weiß, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, auch, auch, ja.
Ja, gegen Kinderkrankheiten und auch gegen Covid?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Ja, Herr Weiß, sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin reint.
Ja, früher war es, hab'n Sie gemacht.
Bankaufmann, weich.
Bankaufmann.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Weiß?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Hab'n Sie Kinder und...
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Eine Tochter, ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Hab'n Sie Stress, äh, bei ihrem Leben?
Ja, manchmal.
Aber es gibt keine bestimmte Stress.
Ja.
Ja, Herr Weiß, wir sind am Ende dieses Gesprächs.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Können Sie mir helfen?
Ja, Herr Weiß, ich habe eine Vernutzung,
aber das ist sehr für etwas zu sagen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen,
nach der Untersuchung auch Blut abnehmen
und ein Rundkernbild, ein Ultraschall durchführen,
nachdem ich alle Ergämpfe erhaltene Bewertung
sofort informieren.
Können Sie bitte auf diese Liga,
legen Sie sich bitte auf diese Liga
zur Untersuchung, Herr Weiß.
Alles klar, danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Hab'n Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich fragen?
Haben Sie Verletzung?
Hatten Sie Verletzung?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Aufstoßen zum Beispiel irgendwo.
Ob ich mich gestoßen habe?
Gestoßen, der aufstoßen wird gestoßen ist etwas anderes.
Aufstoßen ist eher so wie Übelkeit, ja?
Ausstoßen oder?
Ich habe mich nicht gestoßen, ein Moment.
Ich habe mich nicht gestoßen, nein.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Eurologen?
Ja, also einmal im Jahr.
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ich habe ein wenig Post oder Vergrößerung.
Aber Sie sind in Kontrolle, ja?
Okay, danke schön.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Natürlich.
Ich habe nicht gehört, Herr Weiß,
leiden Sie unter Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, habe ich beantwortet.
Okay, könnten wir erst als gesprächlichen Empfang?
Gerne.
Schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen, hätten Sie kurz seid?
Natürlich.
Der Patient heißt Herr Karl Weiß.
Herr Weiß ist 65 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 65 groß und 75 kg schwer.
Herr Weiß, stellte sich heute bei uns
drei Tage ab und zu aufgetretenen
Unterbauch hypokastrik- linkeseitig- hypokastrik-abdominalgie-for.
Wie bitte?
Hypokastrik- hypokastrische- abdominalgie-for.
Unterbauch linkeseitig- hypokastrik- schmerzengforsch.
Oder?
Vielleicht, okay.
Hypokastrik.
Man sagt hier schmerzen im Unterbauch.
Schmerzen im Unterbauch, okay.
Hypokastrik sagt man nicht.
Okay, okay.
Schmerzen im Unterbauch mit Ausstrahlung in die linke Leistung.
Leistung.
Leistung, Leistung, Leistung-for.
Ja, der Patient Herr Weiß berichtet,
dass seine Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen.
Seine Schmerzen sind druckend und stehend.
Insbesondere beim Drucken hat er Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 bis 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Seine Beschwerden treten zum ersten Mal auf.
Gegen seine Beschwerden hat er nur einmal Parastemol angenommen,
aber es hat nicht so gut geholfen.
Als begleitende Symptome hat er auch Feber, 38 Feber mit 38,5.
Er klackte über auch Mausäa, aber kein Erbrochen.
Er hat nie Erbrochen.
Er hat auch wechselnde Stuhlbeschwerden,
manchmal weich und manchmal fest.
Die VKT-Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Der Patient Herr Weiß leitet seit 10 oder 11 Jahren Arterie-Hypertone.
Dagegen nimmt er Ramepril und HCT.
Ramepril hat 5 mg morgens und HCT 12,5 mg morgens ein.
Beide Patient wurden eine Kniegelenk-Operation durchgeführt.
Ich glaube, total...
Er hat keine Allergie und keine Verzünderung.
Er ruft seit 40 Jahren Seinsigarette täglich.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er hat einen Drogenkonsum.
Er treibt als Sport-Patient gehen fast jeden Tag.
Er leidet bei den Eltern an Arterie-Hypertone.
Sein Vater ist ein Mio-Kartinfarktes-Fausturben.
Seine Mutter ist an überall Probleme oder Versturben.
Sie hat eine Schwester.
Sie leidet an Lebensmittelstübs-Weih.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reise Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Herr Weiss ist Rennkna.
Furia hat als Bankkaufmann gearbeitet.
Er ist verheiratet und hat eine Gürunde tochter.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau.
Die Anamnese, die Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Divertikulitis hin.
Er kann als Diagnose enthalten.
Er hat kronische Krankheiten.
Er leistet hoch.
Es gibt keine Schwellung.
Er kann ein Haarenwechselinfekt sein.
Das ist möglich.
Wir können diese Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Manche Laborteste und Untersuchungen durchführen.
Als die Französischen Diagnosen kommen,
haben wir ein Haarenwechselinfektionen oder ein Leistbruch in Betracht.
Ich werde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde bei dieser Untersuchung achten, ob Druckschmerzen,
Abwärtsspannung, Loslassschmerzen.
Wenn eine Schwellung vorhanden ist,
ich werde die Untersuchung im Laborbestimmens abnehmen.
Ich werde ein großes Blöckbild,
eine Leberwerte, eine Hepawerte,
eine Sundoxparameter,
eine Ürentest,
eine Stulltest.
Ich werde diese Werte im Laborbestimmens abnehmen.
Sie haben schon eine Darmspielung gemacht?
Eigentlich habe ich gefragt, ob er seinen Haus war.
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ich erinnere mich, Sie haben mich vorhanden.
Sie haben gefragt, ob er schon eine Operation gehabt hat.
Aber Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob schon mal eine Darmspielung gemacht wurde.
Ja, seit drei Tagen, ja, ich verstehe, ja, das ist, ich, eigentlich bin ich mir ja nicht sicher.
Okay, ich kann diese Informationen, ja, ich kann diese Informationen, ja, den Patienten
wiederstellen.
Sie können mal fragen, ob schon mal eine Darmspiegelung gemacht wurde oder nicht.
Okay, okay.
Normalerweise macht man in Deutschland ab 50, 55 Jahren eine Vorsorge Darmspiegelung.
Das müssten Sie einmal fragen, bitte, das wäre super.
Okay, ja, das bedeutet, das ist unabhängig von den Beschwerden.
Ja, der Patient ist 65, vielleicht früher, ja, verstehe.
Vielleicht, eine diekulose bekannt.
Ja, verstehe.
Vielleicht weiß er das.
Okay, diese Informationen, ja, werde ich, diese Fragen werde ich wiederstellen, den Patienten.
Genau.
Was würden Sie denn machen, wenn jetzt eine die wirkliche Kulitis festgestellt wird?
Ja, der Patient, ja, Kolonokopie, bei der akuten Zeitraum ist Konträntin.
Bei diesem Zeitraum werden wir nur Flüssigkeit geben und mit Antibiotikum.
Ja.
Und ja, als, wir werden auch symptomatische Therapie beginnen.
Das bedeutet, ich werde den Patienten, sollte sich der Verdacht der Akkorde bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten stationell aufnehmen und einen Velosinzugang legen und mit ausreichender
Flüssigkeit Antibiotikum und Analgetikum beginnen.
Was geben Sie denn als Antibiotikum?
Als Antibiotikum, vielleicht, Medrunda Sol, oder?
Auch, auch, noch was?
Medrunda Sol und dritte Gruppe Cephalospirin, oder?
Man kann auch Amoklav geben.
Amoklav kann man auch geben oder Zipofloxazin kann man geben.
Ja, ich, okay, ist Proflux essen, okay, ist Proflux essen.
Man gibt auch Amoklav.
Amoxicillin, Klavolant.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Kann man auch geben.
Okay, Amoxicillin, Klavolant, und auch Medrunda Sol oder Zipofloxazin, okay.
Ja.
Wir können als Antibiotikum diese Therapie beginnen und Spasmolitik und auch Schmerzmittel
gegen seine Beschwerden und nachdem akuten Beschwerden können wir auch Konoskopie durchführen.
Mhm, sehr gut.
Man kann aber auch eine CT-Unsuchung machen, eine Computer-Tomographie, den akuten Schuhk
wenn man eine Computer-Tomographie machen und gucken ob eine Sigma die wird, wird es vorlegt oder nicht.
Mhm, ja.
Und ich gibt es auch eine Empfehlung, ich glaube Ernährung, was war es?
Ernehmung.
Belast auf reiche Ernährung.
Ja, mhm, danke.
Gibst du uns Fragen noch oder ergänzt sie?
Ich möchte eine Ergänzung, Herr Kollege.
Oh, helfe.
Beide ersatzgezüge müssen wir ein paar höfliche Wörter sagen, zum Beispiel vielen Dank für den Hinweis.
Oder danke für die Rückmeldung oder okay, bitte übernommen, Herr Kollege.
Ja.
Es ist, finde ich, gut.
Auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für die Erhneweiß, danke für die Mitarbeiterarbeit, danke schön,
dass Sie das, oder danke für die Rückmeldung, definitiv.
Okay, okay, ich werde am Ende sagen, vielen Dank für alle Empfehlungen und alle Angaben
oder Rückmeldungen, okay.
Aber ich habe das, beider ersatzgezüge wir sind nicht als als nur eine Minimalle,
das ist vegan, aber ich habe das nicht als.
Ja, ich weiß es, Herr Kollege.
Herr Kollege, ich habe das als Profunken gedacht, oder so, gegen die Mitarbeiter,